Why is this hard?
Well because unlike some early
computer vision data sets
we don't typically take an object
put it on a piece of black felt, or
velvet on top of a table and
say okay, that is a fire truck toy.
Right?
Pictures show up more like this,
and I think this also comes from
Kristen cause she has a thing for pandas
and I think also for koalas, all right.
You get great variations in how things
are illuminated, the pose of objects.
The objects are sort of seen in
the background with a bunch of clutter,
they get occluded so here, you know,
there's trees in the way, you know,
the viewpoint, and then, oh, isn't
this a really cute face of a koala.
Yeah, but you know what to another koala
he may not really like this guy because
he, like, ran off with his poker chips,
or something, I don't know.
The idea is that you know, they,
they look different one to another so
the idea that we have these
variations in appearance.
The other thing is that these objects
don't show up again in isolation.
They show up in these cluttered
overlapping environments.
You know, here's this picture of these
two motorcycles one behind the other,
people, of course, walking pedestrians.
We don't get to look at objects
in isolation typically.
Another thing that makes this hard
is the importance of context.
And let me show you three pictures,
okay?
So you take a look at these pictures and
you probably see a person here
talking on his cellphone.
You probably see here an outdoor
scene here with a building and
like some people standing et cetera,
whatever.
You probably see some guy, I don't know
exactly what he's doing, bending down,
maybe picking something up and
here's his shoe over there.
Right?
Right.
Well, hm, you see these regions so
that the phone,
the person, the shoe,
see this single picture here?
Let me blow up that picture
a little bit more, okay?
This patch of intensities is the same
patch here, as here, as here, as there.
So what's a cellphone in one image,
is a shoe in another image.
And that can only be done by
the contexts of everything else
that's around it.
This also makes recognition difficult.
Another challenge is the complexity.
That is, we need to able to compute
things and do it relatively quickly,
because you know, there are thousands
now, now millions of pixels in an image.
We've got, I don't know, 3 to 30, some
tens of thousands of object categories.
We have all sorts of
degrees of freedom of pose.
Yeah, that was cute, I know, right?
So even though it's just a person,
a person can move in many shapes,
although I can move in many fewer
shapes than I used to be able to move.
And there's so many pictures, right?
There are billions of images
indexed by Google Search.
The last number I could
find was that in 2011,
six billion photos were being
uploaded to various things per month.
Okay?
There was a billion camera
phones sold last year.
Okay?
So they all take pictures.
And another interesting indication of
the complexity of recognition, and
of vision in general,
is how much of your brain and
my brain too by the way,
is devoted to visual processing.
There are different estimates,
anywhere from a, a quarter of your
entire cerebral cortex to a half.
And it's the cerebral cortex
that sort of distinguishes you
from an awful lot of other mammals.
So the recognition, the ability for you
to manipulate things so well visually,
seems to be two things, very intense.
It takes a lot of wetware in order for
you to do it.
But I guess evolutionarily it
must have been very useful.
Because you devoted an awful
lot of wetware to handling this